hi I'm Sanjay purohit from infosys
technologies I'm the senior vice
president and the global head for
products platforms and solutions it's
been a very interesting experience to be
at the India economic summit at the
World Economic organised by the world
economic forum here in Mumbai last
couple of days we have had some very
interesting deliberations what I
specifically liked about this entire
summit was the proportionately higher
presence of young people especially
excited about the global shaper program
that the World Economic Forum has
launched and also the role that the
young global leaders are playing because
if we look at the way the world is going
tomorrow belongs to a young people in
the youth and I'm very excited to see
that they are participating here very
very effectively and of course with the
evolution of the social media and other
popular networking practices I expect
this to be a very viral movement where
the young people get involved in
discussing deliberating and solving some
of the most interesting and the most
challenging problems that we have in the
world so tomorrow is the world of
opportunity and I'm happy that the
youngsters are participating in this
forum to address that thank you